who I am in front of a reality that is
building itself without any kind of
control and without any kind of truth
fact approach. If you want to let me
give you an example who I am in front of
a picture of Donald Trump elected
president a talking to Zalinski when we
know this picture does not exist and was
created by a machine which we call you
know synthetic media. who I am as a
user. When I see something that is not
true, but by seeing it at the level of
photo realism, it creates what the two
philosophers, the French ones, Gary and
the have described as the conceptual
existence. There are a lot of questions
about historical facts and I'm not
going, you know, to give a lot of
examples, but is Moses a real historic,
you know, person? is Jesus was really
you know who he was and his Muhammad the
prophet was exactly how he was told to
be it doesn't matter today I mean really
thousand years after you know those
events if they really existed or not
according to and they existed as concept
and thus they exist today so my
individual approach and me who I am in
front of what I'm looking at is
obviously impacted by what I'm seeing
and what I'm watching. And the main
question I'm asking ourselves today,
Michael and and myself, is who I am in
front of something that I know it's
false, but my brain will comprehend it
as true. Where is the line between truth
and false?
[Music]
Benny Berry Simbert, welcome to the
human zero day. I'm so excited to get a
chance to speak with you over these next
20 or so minutes about, you know,
yourself, but also about the world and
about the world that we're living in,
the world that we're moving into. H
you've you've been living at the
forefront and the cutting edge of this
space of this human experience and user
experience in the intersection of AI,
machine learning and and and
identities. if you will, or the new
forms of identity. So, a lot for us to
unpack today. You're the head of AI
research and and ethics at at
metaphysics, but you've done a lot of
different things before and and so uh
you've been around the block. Uh Benny,
tell me a little bit about how you got
into this world of synthetic media and
you know, the new ways of thinking
through identities.
>> Thank you for having me today, Michael.
I mean it means a lot and and being able
to discuss a and we will discuss that a
little bit later today. The concept of
truth in front a of what our eyes or our
screen driven eyes are seeing is
something very important for us as human
being to sustain as human being in the
future. So I'm very happy to have the
opportunity to discuss that with you. on
my side you know Einstein I think said
that you know the best way for God to
act incognito is to use hazard so my
life is just a kind of accident if you
know what uh and a lot of meetings a lot
of stuff that I have brought me to the
point today that I'm heading you know
ethics and research for a company that
is dealing with a synthetic VFX and an
AIdriven VFX I mean virtual effect my
background is a not a tech background
20 years ago I wanted to discuss
philosophy at the level of a PhD. At
this time nobody
seemed to care about the concept of
ethics in tech. Uh but I wanted to deal
with this because I had this very weird
relationship and meetings that I wanted
to have with Niete
on his vision on science and positivism.
So this is why and this is how I came to
the world of ethics. A after those PhD
studies a at this time you know leaving
from an academic career especially in
Israel was very complicated and
especially when it came to philosophy at
this time humanities were not anymore
the the nice thing to study in the
universities everybody was looking know
for something a little bit more tangible
etc etc so I went to the to the world of
high-tech I started my career very very
you know at the bottom just to
understand how we deal with
and how I could bring a little bit more
value by bringing my world, my realm to
a world where a greedy capitalism was
really, you know, rooting at the time.
I'm speaking about, you know, around 20
years ago. It was just about profit. It
was just about creating money no matter
what you used to do, no matter what you
will do and what no matter what will be
the impact on humanity and on the
planet. And I think that 20 years now
you know after we can definitely rely on
on this statement because I mean if we
look at the decentralized technology
i.e. crypto bitcoin it's killing the
planet as at the past that is incredibly
high and I don't think that you know
anybody on our side knows the impact of
the new tech on the human brain and the
way we interact now from a pure
scientific point of view. I think that
when you walk the streets, you
understand how tech has impacted our
life. So just to wrap it up,
educate education as a philosopher of
sciences, an experience as a tech guy,
I'm coding also and today I'm in front
of you, Michael, with those I would say
two hats to discuss the future of our
tech.
>> Absolutely. Absolutely. So Benny, help
me understand a little bit
the world of
humans and identities in the context of
AI from your perspective.
How does that look like? How does that
work?
>> So it is it is the central question of
what we are dealing with today. And and
if you allow me, let's begin maybe by
the end as usual.
there is no temporality the way we see
it in from pure linear point of view as
you know Michael uh so we'll begin by
the end the end is that a lot of people
are thinking or feeling that AI will
destroy humanity
and we heard not a long time ago some
big people in in in San Francisco in the
valley asking for more atal I mean a
stop on the EI research because they
were afraid of what could be the impact
of this technology on humanity itself
uh you are touching a very very
important and very precise point here.
The concept of identity or if you want
to this concept of who I am as an
individual in a social contract that is
completely different than the one that
we used to to to use or to enjoy from
until the AI boom. Um
technology is a tool.
The same way the select you know life
was a tool a techniques if you want to
in the hands of our ancestors.
This technology is not supposed to
change completely the way we are from a
puretologic point of view.
>> But there is something that is very
interesting for us to understand and to
discuss. It's this concept of who is
this I, me and mine at the age of AI and
we're going to take some distance from
the pure I would say Fudian or Yian if
you want to you know point of view in
terms of identity who I am in this world
but we're going to take you know a a
very specific point to begin and to
start this journey is who this is this I
at the level of AI meaning who I am in
front of a reality that is building
itself without any kind of control and
without any kind of truth fact approach.
If you want to let me give you an
example who I am in front of a picture
of Donald Trump elected president a
talking to Zalinski when we know this
picture does not exist and was created
by a machine which we call you know
synthetic media. who I am as a user.
When I see something that is not true,
but by seeing it at the level of photo
realism, it creates what the two
philosophers, the French ones, Gary and
the have described as the conceptual
existence. There are a lot of questions
about historical facts and I'm not
going, you know, to give a lot of
examples, but is Moses a real historic,
you know, person? is Jesus was really
you know who he was and his Muhammad the
prophet was exactly how he was told to
be it doesn't matter today I mean really
thousand years after you know those
events if they really existed or not
according to and they existed as concept
and thus they exist today
>> so my individual approach and me who I
am in front of what I'm looking at is
obviously impacted by what I'm seeing
and what I'm watching. And the main
question I'm asking ourselves today,
Michael, and and myself, is who I am in
front of something that I know it's
false, but my brain will comprehend it
as true.
>> Where is the line between truth and
false?
>> Wow.
>> I'm not there as an individual. a a lot
to unpack but and I'll start with the
last statement that you just said
because the you raised an important
question of saying who I am when I am
facing information that I know is false
but looks true.
So let's talk for a second about the
premise of knowing that it's false
because that's not that's not a trivial
feat in a world today, right? I mean,
there's the the technology that it's
evolving is is making it harder and
harder to identify what is real and what
is fake, whether it's in an online
setting or whether it's in a real-time
communication setting like this. And so,
let let's stop for just a second and
talk about the role of technology and
solutions to even just help us
understand what is real and what is
fake, whether we're going to believe it
or and who we are at the face of it.
That's that's a question that I want to
get to in a second. How do we what's
happening today in the context of being
able to discern what is real and what is
fake?
First of all, this is not a new problem.
It's a very old problem. This problem
has began at the beginning started at
the beginning of our you know human
history when we began we we we've
started you know to paint our stories on
walls. Take you know the the cave of
Lasco in France with those you know
horses and coals painted you know 3,000
years ago. or even more I would say
6,000 years ago. Is it true? Is it
false? Is it the reality? We don't know.
At the moment that we represent
something, you know, physically outside
of our own perception of our brain, the
question of truth or false is asked. So
it's not about who we are in front of
this. It's about who we are in front of
our presentation of a reality that is
pursued only by your own brain. I mean
we don't see the same thing Michael and
and and myself at the moment. We are the
same place. We are living the same
reality but we we don't see you know the
same thing and we are not facing the
same experience.
I'm going to use again my philosophy
background but there is a very important
philosopher of technology. His name is
Gunter Anders. He was a German you know
philosopher 1956. This is you know his
main work. It's called the obsidencies
of you know the human being and
everything that he was talking about he
was calling this the ghost effect of
radio and television. What are we
listening to when we listen to radio? Is
it true? Is it the truth? Or is it a
ghost? Meaning a representation of
something that already is already
passed. And I think that what you are
talking about is this ontological I
would say relationship that we have in
front of something that represents the
reality outside of our brain. The main
problem today my dear friend Michael is
that with the technology that we are
using today we can fool the fools. It
means that the the border or the I would
say you know the boundary between what
is true and false is very blurred and
it's more and more difficult today to
understand what is true and what is
false. is a fact and what is a synthetic
you know fact
but you know I'm very happy to know that
technology comes also with its own
vaccine I would say if you allow me to
speak like that when you create a virus
you create a vaccine and I know that a
lot of companies in this world are
working to create a lot of tools that
are going to enable empower users in
their user experience to understand and
to get you know all the weapons to
understand what is true and what is
false
but you're
this technology AI and more effectively
the generative approach of AI which
doesn't allow the human being to be able
to impact how the machines are going to
be representing the reality. This is
really really freaking out a lot of
people including me but you know
technology as I said can be used also to
reverse the karma will and to bring back
the truth the way it must be brought.
So, so now let's go into the world of
the of the user experience. You
mentioned that there's two pieces to it.
There's the the art of can we
empirically identify what is real or
fake, a truth and a lie. And then
there's the human aspect and the human
that has to then engage with the content
sometimes experiencing one thing getting
but and getting some signals that that
something is not what it is. and then
they have to make a decision. And I
think this was probably relevant for
both you know any online interaction
with information as well as even in a
business setting where you know we have
in a rising increase of social
engineering and fishing using AI
generated content and there's some
levels of expectation that humans will
have the tools to make the right
decisions at the right time when
confronted with these attacks if you
Um,
what's your take on the human element
that's experiencing
this influx of content and information
and how how are humans going to deal
with it or how are we dealing with it
today?
>> Again, we are going to get back to the
past as usual and not too far in 1984.
It's not the year, it's the book. And I
think if you want to see how we live our
lives today, you need to get back to
this book and to understand that we are
not in a very good shape as a group and
as individuals.
>> There is two things here that you are
saying Michael. The first one is the
flow of information that has increased
drastically for the last you know couple
of decades. The quantity of information
that we are in front of on a daily basis
is is insane and does not allow you to
stop to reflect and to ask yourself and
to even think about what you are
consuming in terms of news. The second
part is obviously all the techniques or
all the tactics that some you know I
would say non-co players are using you
know to deceive you and to force you to
do something you don't want to do. And
here I'm speaking from a purely business
point of view but also public point of
view. There are governments in this
world that are using this technology to
fabric public consent and to make sure
that they are controlling their people
or the other people. And I think that
you know what we see in Ukraine, Russia,
what we saw in Israel, Palestine, what
we saw lately also during the US
elections was just showing us that it is
increasing day after day this try to
control and to fabric if you want to
like Noamsky was saying this public
consent. That's that's the first point.
The second point I would say you know on
this topic which is very important I
don't think that we are stupid and
turning humanity into something that
does not able to understand what is true
and what is false. It's getting back to
a kind of world where spirituality and
not ethics was reading the world. If you
think so I mean words have meaning you
know and I I love words. We say we
believe in God but we say we believe in
truth. Is that the same thing?
Is that something that we need to
believe in when it comes to truth or is
that something we need to acknowledge as
I would say a collective approach to
reality? The best way also again to
illustrate this and I'm going to get
back again to philosophy. It's the cave
of plateau. If you think about that a
group of men, they were chained in a
cave. They were looking at their own
shadows on the world and they were
believing that it was the truth until
two of them went out saw the sun in
front of their eyes. It was so hurtful
that one of them asked to be brought
back to his slave status and to believe
again that their own shadows are
reality. I think that Michael this is
really what we are living in today.
There are people that are ready to look
at the real the way it is even if this
is you know hurtful and they are the
ones that want and ask to be deceived
because this is easy and this is less
painful but people are not stupid and
if the school I would say the public
school I'm a big fan of the concept of
republican public school if the public
school is doing its job meaning to teach
our children to think write count and
read we're going to be okay but I began
and started this statement with think.
We need to teach our kids to think by
themselves and not to equip them only
with tool that can be also tools that
can be also deceived by their you know
developers. You know, it's really
interesting because,
you know, I'm a I'm coming in into this
from a cyber security background. And,
you know, in cyber security, you look at
the human and you ask security
professionals what's worked, what
doesn't work, and they talk about, you
know, a few main pieces, but there's the
the firewall piece. Let's let's create
these protective measures. Then there's
the at the end the other end there's the
well let's let's make sure that they
that even if they make a mistake that
that mistake you know gets stopped
before some money goes out or some
access gets gets given. And then there's
the middle piece which is you know in
between those two worlds the human is
confronted with a decision where they're
faced with a potential attack and they
need to decide whether to act on it or
not. And at least from cyber security
perspective, it seems like the counting
on the human and counting on the human's
ability to make the right decision
reliably
that belief is unfortunately decreasing.
And I'm hearing a different a different
optimistic viewpoint from yourself.
>> Definitely. I'm a big fan of human and I
a big believer if we get back to this
concept of the human touch in technology
and why because we cannot be the slaves
of what we are creating and I'm going to
use again goodanders
and his book you know in 1956 the
obscences of of human being he explained
in this book that at the moment that we
don't understand how a technology is
built we become it slaves and We create
a kind of what he calls a promoter and
shame meaning you are ashamed of the
creator that you have created like
Frankenstein and his creator if you want
to and we become its slaves but I'm a
strong believer Michael that humanity as
a world and us as individuals we have
the capacity we have the reliance but
more than everything else we have this
very specific interbeing relationship
with nature and by nature I'm not
speaking about what is been, but about
what is around us, the cosmos, if you
want to. We have a very specific
relationship that allows us to be
optimistic. Why? Because we always have
found a way to confront ourselves with
our own contradictions and to if you
want to use an hegelian concept
to preserve and move forward. So, we're
going to win this world. The machine
will not control our life, will not
create synthetic realities without us
fighting it with our nails. Because
reality and the perception of reality is
what is turning us into a different
animal than the co, the wolf or even the
insect that is, you know, populating
your garden. We understand what is
reality. maybe in a wrong way, but we
have a very specific interconnected
relationship to this concept of reality.
>> Benny, this was such an awesome
conversation. Thank you so much for
spending this time with me. Um, we're
talking, you know, this is December
10th, 2024. Uh, Sora came out just a few
hours ago
>> indeed. And and so a a really timely
moment to have this conversation where
potentially we're this day will go down
as sort of this this new additional one
of many inflection points of where um
hyper realism and and world and are
colliding and the continent is created.
So wishing all of us best of luck
the most exciting time to be alive
probably with the least predictableness
of where things are heading but I I join
your optimism. So thank you so much
Benny.
>> Thank you very much Michael. You have a
good one.
>> Thank you.